يتحدث عن خسائر روسيا فادحه في دونياس
ومحادثات امريكيه روسيه السريه لمنع تصعيد
اوسع
قبل يوم من الانتخابات النصفيه الجمهوريون
يتعهدون باستعاده الكونجرس في الانتخابات
المقرره غدا
تظاهرات مستمره في سنندجه وبشهر وطهران
واحتجاجات جديده في جامعات شمال غربي
البلاد الغالبيه الكرديه
[موسيقى]
احييكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره الاخباريه
من العربيه صباح الخير البدايه من اخر
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا فقد نقلت صحيفه
عن المسؤولين امريكيين قولهم انا مستشاره
الامن القومي الامريكي
للرئيس الروسي في محاوله للحد من مخاطر
المسؤولون الذين لم تعلن الصحيفه عن
اسمائهم ان المحادثات كانت تهدف ايضا
لتحذير موسكو من استخدام اسلحه النوويه او
غيرها من اسلحه الدمار الشامل كما تهدف
الى تجنب مخاطر التصعيد وابقى اي قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه وليس مناقشه الوصول الى
تسويه للحرب في اوكرانيا
من جانبه الرئيس
اعلن ان روسيا تستعد لشن هجمات جديده على
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا مبينا
ان مسكوت تتكبد خسائر فادحه في هجماتها
المستمره في اقليم دونيت شرق البلاد
الاخرى على البنيه التحتيه وعلى مرافق
الطاقه في المقام الاول لهذا السبب احتاجت
روسيا صواريخ ايرانيه نحن نستعد للرد
الهجمات الروسيه القاسيه
مستمره لكن رغم ذلك يتكبد العدو خسائر
فادحه هنا ورغم كل هذه الخسائر تواصل
روسيا الدفع بالمرتزقه والمجندين الى
حدفهم اشكر جنودنا الذين يتحملون هذا
الضغط الرهيب ويستمرون بصمودهم مدافعين
ببطوله عن مواقعنا
الهجمه بالصواريخ والمسيرات الانتحاريه
يراها الغرب علامه على تراجع الروسي في
المعارك على الارض وفي المقابل تحكم روسيا
قبضتها يوما بعد يوم على المقاطعه التي
ضمتها مؤخرا في جنوب اوكرانيا وشرقاها
فيما تبقى خيرسون مفتاح المواجهه خلال
الايام المقبله
الدلائل كثيره فقد بدات اوكرانيا في تحشيد
قواتها على طقوم خاصه مركزه على المدفعيه
مثل قاذفته هيمارس ومدفعي ام 270
الامريكيين هو مداهما 80 كيلو مترا
ومدفعي ان
777 البريطاني الصنع ومده 40 كيلو مترا
هذا المدفع كانت شركه بي اي اي سيستمز قد
اوقفت تصنيعه منذ فتره ولكن تسربت مؤخرا
اشارات عن تفكيرها في بد تصنيعه من جديد
نظرا للنجاحات التي نتجت عن استخدامه في
اوكرانيا كيف لا تستخدم فقط منظومات
مدفعيه غربيه بل تلقت كذلك دعما من
سلوفاكيا بمدفع سوزانا وبولندا التي قدمت
لكيف مدفع اكراب وكلاه ماذاتي الحركه
روسيا من جهتها مصممه على استراتيجيه
استهداف اكثر البنا التحتيه الاوكرانيه
حيويه وخاصه المتعلقه بالطاقه لاجبار
اوكرانيا على التراجع وحتى الان يثق كل من
الجانبين بقدرته على الحسمه بينما تبتعد
فرص التفاوض انثى العربيه
الى الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه حيث
نشرت صحيفه نيويورك
في مجال الامن السيبراني سلسله من
العمليات نفذتها مجموعه روسيه للتاثير على
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعيه نيويورك تايمز اضافت
ان وكاله روسيه تدخلت في انتخابات امريكا
2016-2020
تكرروا ممارستها الارنب وعشره الصحيفه الى
ان حسابات المزيفه بدات حمله للتاثير على
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه كما
جاء في المقال ان التاثير الروسي على
الانتخابات اقل من عام 2016 لكن موسكو
تواصل التدخل
[موسيقى]
يوم فقط يفصلنا عن اكثر المعارك شراسه في
الانتخابات الامريكيه وقبل ساعات من
الاستحقاق تعهد الجمهوريون باستعاده
منتصف الولايه الحاسمه هذا الاسبوع في ما
اثار الديمقراطيون على انهم ما زالوا في
المعركه قبل ساعتين على هذا الاستحقاق
هذه الانتخابات ليست استثناء بل انها
اختيار بين رؤيتين مختلفتين تماما لامريكا
لقد قلت منذ البدايه عندما خط الانتخابات
ان هدفي كان بناء اقتصاد من القاعده الى
القمه ومن المنتصف الى الخارج واقول لكم
انه تحول اساسي وهو ناجح مقارنه اقتصاديات
الشعار جعلوا امريكا قويه مره اخرى
ثلاثه رؤساء في خطوه من الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين على حد سواء لتعبئتناهم
مع اقتراب موعد انتخابات منتصف الولايه
يسارع الحزبان الديمقراطي والجمهوري على
حد سواء الى تعبئه ناخبيهم في بنسلفانيا
حيث المعركه الانتخابيه النصفيه المصيريه
حضنت ولايه بنسلفانيا الرئيسيه ثلاثه
رؤساء قبل عمليه اختراع حاسمه ستضع اسس
الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 20 24
اوباما مساندا الرئيس الحالي جو بايد
المقابل ترامب الذي لا يزال يتمتع بقبضه
قويه على الحزب الجمهوري وامام التجمع
حاشد من الجمهوريين يستهزئ الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على قله عدد
الناخبين في تجمع منافسه الديمقراطيين
الانتخابي بولايه بن سلمان
[موسيقى]
جدا بدا الامر وكانه حشد من 200 شخص
في المقابل نزل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الى الساحه والمفارقه هنا انه كان يتجنب
في ما سبق اعتلاء المنصات لجمع تبرعات
لحزبه معتبرا ان انتخابات منتصف الولايه
ستكون لحظه فارقه في مصير الديمقراطيه
داخل الولايات المتحده
ومع مساعي الحزب الجمهوري للسيطره على
الكونجرس حذر الرئيس الامريكي السابق
باراك اوباما من ان سيطره الجمهوريين على
الكونجرس ستجعلهم ينتقمون من منافسهم
السياسيين في اشاره منه الى انهم قد
يعزلون الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
[موسيقى]
ومن المقرر ان تحدد انتخابات التجديد
النصفي الحزب الذي سوف يسيطر على الكونغرس
فهل ستكون من نصيب الحزب الديمقراطي الذي
يسعى جاهدا للاحتفاظ بالغالبيه الضئيله
التي يتمتع بها في الكونغرس ام من نصيب
الحزب الجمهوري الذي يحاول اعاده قبضته
على مجلس الشيوخ والنواب سلطان العربيه
[موسيقى]
خرجت تظاهرات الليليه في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه خاصه في سندج وبشهر وطهران فيما
جامعاته شمال غربي البلاد الغالبيه
الكرديه خرجت فيها احتجاجات جديده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم من جديد في السودان اكد اللواء
فضل الله برمان ناصر الرئيس حزب الامه
المكلف خلال استقباله وفدانا من الحزب
الاتحادي الديمقراطي برئاسه محمد الحسن
المرغني انا السودانيين قادرون على تجاوز
المحن ومعالجه جراحه الوطن مطالبا جميع
القوى السياسيه والتوريه بالمضيق قدما
اتجاه انهاء الوضع الراهن عبر الحل
السياسي من جانبه اكد ابراهيم المدني رئيس
القطاع السياسي في الحزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي دعم الحزبي للعمليه السياسيه
التي تستند على مشروع الدستور الانتقالي
مشيدا بجهود كل القوه الثوريه والسياسيه
لانهاء الوضع القائم
هي توافدوا قاده العالم اعتبارا من اليوم
الى المناخ الى مؤتمر المناخ كوب 27 في
مصر فيما حذر الامين العام للامم المتحده
في شرم الشيخ
جميعهم التقوا في شرم الشيخ في اول ايام
قمه المناخ المؤتمر الذي يحمل عنوان
الاضرار والخسائر شهد في يومه الاول تسلم
مصر رئاسه المؤتمر
واكد المجتمعون على اتفاق من حيث المبدا
على ادراج ملف التعويضاتك احدى الاليات
للدول المتضرره من الانبعاثات الحراريه
واللا يقترب من التعويضات لا يتحدث عن
التعويضات المساله على قدر كبير من
الحساسيه وسببت عدم حدوث اي تقدم فيها هو
اقرار بحق هذه الدول في اجراء النقاش حول
كيفيه تمويل الاضرار والخسائر التي يعانون
منها السنوات الماضيه
لتفعيل ملف التمويل المقدري ب 100 مليار
دولار سنويا احنا محتاجين على الاقل 100
مليار دولار في السنه التعامل مع قضيه
تغير الملف الوقت الحالي وللاسف ما وصلناش
للمستوى ده عندنا حوالي 80 مليار فالمؤتمر
هيبص في الموضوع ده ثاني حاجه موضوع
التكيف ان هو فيه اثار لتغير المناخ حتى
لو عرفت انقلل الانبعاثات برده هتكون
موجوده عندنا زي ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر
زي اللي همم الفيضانات والجفاف وثالث حاجه
هي تخفيض اللي انبعاثات اللي هو اصل
المشكله ان احنا نوصل للمستوى همم
وما يزيدش عن واحد ونصف درجه مئويه همم
ارتفاع في متوسط درجه الحراره بحدود عام
2100 ولكن تبقى القضايا الخلافيه
فهناك شبه اتفاق على استحاله الوصول الى
انخفاض الانبعاثات الحراريه بنسبه درجه
ونصف في المئه العلم بيؤكد هذا التقرير
العلميه كلها بتؤكد ان نحن لا نسير على
مسار سيحفظنا في هذا بل يؤدي الى ربما
الوصول الى درجات درجتين ونصف او ثلاث
درجات او اكثر لو استمرنا على هذا المعدل
الك
ثير الغضبي
تبالي بالاضرار المواجهه لبلادهم وشعوبهم
واذا تمنيفورس
كاذبه كثيره منذ اتفاق باريس وجزيرتي هي
من اصغر الجزر في العالم ان الشعور بانها
تتعرض لاكبر الخسائر بسبب سياسات الدول
الصناعيه
ومن المنتظر ان يحضر قاده العالم لنقاش
كافه السبل لوضع تصورات لازمه تغير المناخ
على ان ينتهي المؤتمر يوم 18
بمجموعه من التوصيات وحتى لا يتحول مؤتمر
شرم الشيخ الى مجرد جلسات للحوار يراهن
كثيرون على ان تدهور الوضع البيئي واضراره
على الانسان قد تكون دافعه لقاده العالم
لاتخاذ المزيد من الاجراءات في محاوله
لانقاذ الارض وسكانها من اضرار التغير
البيئي احمد عثمان العربيه شرم الشيخ
الاسماك الماليه والاقتصاديه والتداعيتها
الاجتماعيه في اوروبا
برفض متزايد لموجه اللاجئين فقط تظهر سكان
قريه كلاك في غرب فرنسا ضد مشروع يقضي
بتوطين البدعه عشرات من اللاجئين
هذه واحده من العائلات التي ينص مشروع
عمده كلاك على استخدام المزيد منها الى
البلده لدمجها في المجتمع من خلال مهنه
ربيعه ومحمد سوريان كرديان من عين عرب وصل
الى هنا قبل عام مع اولادهما الاربعه قبل
ان تنقسم البلده حول استخدام اللاجئين
الحمد لله جينا نعرف فرنسا سلمونا بيت
الحمد لله البيت كل شيء موجود بقلبه فورا
حط اولادي بالمدرسه والحمد لله اتعلم
اللغه الفرنسيه وكله مبسوطين منه المدرسين
والانسات وانا الضيعه اللي هاي اللي فيها
انا باشكرهم عن جد كلهم محترمين
حول استخدام المزيد منهم ويرى بعضهم
مدعوما من حزب استرداد فرنسا الذي يتزعبه
اليمين المتطرف
لهويه بلدهم
عندما يذهب احد الى محطه القطار سانشاغل
في مارسيليا يلاحظ ان لا احد هناك يتحدث
الفرنسيه
الى بلدنا عليهم ان يحترموا قيامنا على
بعد مئات الامطار تظاهره تدعمها قوى
اليسار راى مشاركون فيها ان استقبال
لاجئين يغني ثقافه فرنسا وراى اخرون انه
يجب استقبالهم بشكل افضل
يجب ان نتحرك جميعا
الذين يطرقون ابوابنا هربا من الحرب
والجوع
من الطريق الذي عملتهم بها فرنسا يجب
استقالهم بانسانيا قبل ان تنفض التظاهره
المعاديه للمهاجرين انضم اليها شبان من
بينهم ملثمين راحوا يهتفون فرنسا لنا قبل
ان تطاردهم الشرطه التي استخدمت الغاز
المسيله للدموع لمنع الاحتكاك بين
التظاهراتين
اذا الاولى مع فرنسا المنفتحه وضد الفاشيه
والمستعده لمساعده الذين يحتاجون الى
المساعده والاخرى تظاهره مع فرنسا
المتضامنه مع نفسها فقط والتي يخشى
المشاركون فيها من غزو يهدد ثقافتها هذا
البلد وح طه والنموذج حسين قنيبر العربيه
من قريه كلاك غرب فرنسا
عن مصادر ان شركه تويتر اتصلت بموظفينا من
من انهت خدماتهم بموجب خطه المالك الجديد
العماس لتخفيف النفقات طالبه منهم العوده
الى عملهم وعنقله عن اشخاص عن وصفتهم
بالمطلعين قولهم ان بعض المواظفين السوري
عن طريق الخطا والطلب منهم العوده كما تم
التخلي عن اخرين قبل ان تدرك الاداره وان
عملهم وخبراتهم قد تكون ضروريتا لبناء
الميزات الجديده التي يخطط لها ماسك
ملكه تويتر الملياردير لهم ماسك خلفي
تغريده له انه سيتم تعليق الحسابات
الوهميه والمزيفه والحسابات الساخره
واعدفه ماسك في تغريده منفصله ان تويتر
اصدر سابقا ملف تحذير ومع سياسه المحتوى
في تويتر لن يكون هناك تحضير ولا
استثناءات مؤكدا ان اي تغيير في الاسم
سيؤدي الى فقدان المؤقت لعلامه الاختيار
التي تم التحقق منها
دخل بالمغسله واثار معه الشك والريبه الى
ان تحقق التنبؤات هذا اللغز لكن يبدو ان
القديمه اعظم
قضيه الثمانيه دولارات لا مفر منها لان
هذه التسعيره الشهريه مقابل وضع العلامه
الزرقاء على الحسابات الموثقه دخلت حيز
التنفيذ في الولايات المتحده وكندا
واستراليا ونيوزيلندا والمملكه المتحده
ورغم كل ما يجري فانماسك متمسك باجراءته
التي يراها الافضل فهو عازم ايضا على
انهاء زمن لقطات الشاشه التي وصفها
بالسخيفه معلنا ان عصر النصوص الطويله
والمقاطع التي يصل وقتها الى اكثر من نصف
ساعه وبدقه عاليه سيظهر في الشهر المقبل
الملياردير الامريكي الذي طرد نصفه موظفي
وتر مظن في خطواته للانتقادات توقفه هو
الانقطاع الانفاق الاعلاني من كبرى
الشركات يهز عرشاه ووفق صحيفه الفاينشل
تايمز فان ماسك يمر بفتره الانتقاليه قرر
خلالها ان يحيط نفسه بمجموعه مساعدين
مخلصين وموثوق بهم في غرفه الحرب السريه
التي كان فيها ذراعه الايمن والايسر شخصان
يدعان جيسون كلك اسود
اما مؤسسه تويتر جاك دورسي الذي شارك في
انشاء الشبكه الاجتماعيه عام 2006 و
غادرها قبل سنه يبدو انه يرجح كفه ماسك
التي اختارت اقاله الموظفين على ان تنهار
الشركه الزرقاء تدريجيا بمقدار 4 ملايين
يوميا لكنه في ذات الوقت قدم اعتذارا
مغلفا بقلب ازرق
[موسيقى]
ماسك الواثق بحلوله هو بالفعل غير مدرك ان
الامور معقده اكثر مما يظن هكذا يراه
بروسلي الذي شغل سابقا نائب رئيس تويتر
عبر عن صدمته بملك المنصه الجديد قائلا
لا يعرف ما الذي يفعله ويثير بتصرفاته غير
الديمقراطيه قلق الجميع اسراء الصغير
العربيه
اعلن المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الدفاع
السعوديه العميد الركن تركي المالكي سقوطه
مقاتله من نوع اف 15 نتيجه خلل فنيه اثناء
مهمه تدريبيه روتينيه بمنطقه التدريب
التابعه لقاعده الملك عبد العزيز الجويه
في المنطقه الشرقيه مؤكدا النشاط الطاقه
الجويه المكون من ضابطين وانه لا يوجد اي
اصابات او خسائر على الارض نتيجه سقوط
الطائره
تعاهدت كوريا الشماليه بردا عسكري حق ضد
التدريبات العسكريه التي تشريها كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده منذ الاسبوع
الماضي قائله ان المناورات استفزاز واضح
وانها مناورات حربيه خطيره جاء هذا
التحذير وسط سلسله التجارب صاروخيه اجرتها
الشماليه في الاثريه الاخيره بما في ذلك
اربعه صواريخ بالستيه اطلقت يوم السبت بعد
ايام على ختام الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه اكبر تدريبات على الاطلاق للقوات
الجويه
تستمر المعارك بين سكان المحليين مدعومين
من الجيش الصومالي من جهه وبين مقاتلي
حركه الشباب في عده مناطق بوسط الصماء
المتبعه
تشتغل المعارك بين المسلحين القبليين
المدعومين من الجيش الصومالي ومقاتلي حركه
الشباب المواليه للتنظيم القاعده في عده
بلدات وقرن في اقليم ايران وصدصومال الجيش
الشمالي تحدث عن مقتل اكثر من 100 عنصر من
حركه الشباب في المعارك الاخيره بالاقليم
واستعاده بلدات وقرى الاستراتيجيه تتوسع
الرقعه المعارك التي تشاركها احيانا طائره
مسيره للقياده الامريكيه في افريقيا دعما
للجيش والقوه المحليه قبائل بولايه الجنوب
الغربي الشمال تنضم الى العشائر السائره
وتقول انها حمله السلاح لتحرير مناطقها من
حركه شباب التي تصيطر على مناطق واسعه من
الجنوب ووسط البلاد منذ 15 عاما
عمري اثنين وخمسون عاما واقسم بالله انني
ساحاربهم جنتهم محاربتهم
اعتقنا
يؤكد مسؤول ولايه جنوب الغربي شومال انه
ولايتهم باعتت جزءا من الحرب الجاريه ضد
الحركه مشيرين الى ان المعركه في مناطقهم
ستحسن سريعا
وحمانت اوفر اواجه نداء الى الصوماليين في
اقليم جنوب غربيه الصومال ليس امامهم سوى
قتال عدونا المتمثل في حركه الشباب قمنا
بجوله في مناطق عده بالاقليم لتعبئه
الجميع لشني عمليات المشتركه لقتلها هؤلاء
وان نحظ حظو الاقاليم التي طردتهم
وتاتي هذه المعارك في وقت تعيش المناطق
عديده من البلاد حاله جفاف عريمن يعد
القسوه منذ 40 عاما عبد الرحمن البخاري
العربيه مقديشو